42 years ago when the world of computing was
just taking shape physicist Richard Feynman
took the stage at MIT to give a keynote speech
he started by admitting that he didn't know what
a keynote speech was but then went on to talk
about something that he thought nobody else
at the conference would talk about what he
shared was his vision for Quantum Computing
Quantum Computing is a technology that
is coming into its own right now and
the breakthroughs that we're seeing today were
in many ways anticipated by Feynman's
brilliant insights in his 1981 lecture
This video is a collaboration with
Q-CTRL a global Quantum technology
company headquartered in Sydney that makes this
technology useful through its infrastructure
software products for Quantum Computing and
Quantum sensing many of the animations that
I'll use in this video are from Q-CTRL's
educational platform called Black Opal
Feynman dared to speak about quantum computers the
same year that IBM released their first personal
computers it was a time when computers were big
bulky machines primarily used by businesses for
recordkeeping with tiny amounts of storage
and RAM the internet didn't exist and yet
Feynman already wanted to push computers to
their limit he titled his talk simulating
physics with computers something that meant he
had to first admit that even physicists don't
understand the world perfectly I'm not absolutely
sure of anything and there many things I don't
know anything about I don't feel frightened by
not knowing things even today there's a lot of
physics that we still don't understand and
so we need computers to help us learn more
but what kind of physics do we want to learn
about some physics can be approximated just
fine by solving things like differential equations
Feynman gave this speech after people had traveled
to the Moon after all using math and physics that
could for a large part be computed by hand when
Feynman says simulating physics with computers
he is referring to the task of trying to mimic
or copy physics to create an accurate simulator
of our world he isn't talking about other tasks
like adding numbers or sending emails those
you can do just fine on a normal computer we
already do a lot of simulation on computers to
approximate nature Feynman vision was to move
away from approximations and invent a computer
that could do exactly the same as nature Feynman
says that the physical world is quantum mechanical
and therefore the proper problem is the simulation
of quantum physics quantum physics refers to
the world of the very small since a quantum
is the smallest possible unit of something on
the quantum scale particles can seem to behave
stangely existing in a cloud of probabilities
only collapsing into a definite state once we
measure them conventional bits in a computer ones
and zeros can't keep track of quantum information
Feynman 1981 speech was actually the first work
to specifically discuss the construction of a
machine that would operate on quantum mechanical
principles using hardware that employs quantum
physics itself to keep track of it accurately
he came up with just one rule for something
that would match his vision that the size of the
computer would only need to be proportional to
the size of the physical system it was simulating
that is he said if you want to explain this much
physics I can do it exactly and I need a certain
sized computer if doubling the volume of space
and time means I'll need an exponentially
larger computer I consider that against the
rules that's followed by a comment saying I
make up the rules I'm allowed to do that most
conventional computers fail this rule when trying
to simulate nature because every time you add just
one more particle to keep track of you're adding
a near Infinity of new places it could be and it
becomes exponentially harder to compute Feynman
says that to get around this we should let the
computer itself be built of quantum mechanical
elements which obey quantum mechanical laws
so what are these quantum mechanical elements
well I'm going to use the Black Opal platform
to demonstrate this next bit as it says here
the fundamental unit of quantum information
is the qubit in normal computing we have bits
of information that can be either a zero or a
one but for a cubit the information is much
more crowded it can be pictured as a sphere
and we need two numbers to specify how much the
qubit is one and how much it is zero these qubits
especially when you have multiple of them contain
a lot more information than conventional bits can
hold and so given the fact that we hope to have
quantum computers with millions of qubits one
day this will take us to a realm far beyond what
conventional computers are able to do here's a
qubit that we can play around with the top of it
is marked as the zero state and the bottom being
marked as the one state if the blue line is the
state of our qubit then we can move it all around
the sphere swapping from zero to one or somewhere
in between there's an infinite range of possible
options where the state of the qubit can live on
the surface of the sphere and that corresponds
to the increased information storage in quantum
computers there's more than one way to make a
qubit and really it comes down to needing two
energy levels that are separated by some known
gap that's because with quantum physics it's a
lot about energy at its fundamental scale and
with energy you can have something called
a ground state which is the lowest energy
of a system and then an excited state where it's
you know elevated one above that and an example
given here in this energy level diagram shows I
think a particle in a ground state in blue that
when it's hit with light it might absorb some
energy and thus go to an excited state where it
has more energy than it did in the ground state
and it could give off or emit that energy to
go back down and that is fundamentally the
the kind of dynamic needed to make a qubit
one practical way that people can engineer that
kind of system is with trapped ions the ion in
this case is an atom that has lost an electron
and so has gained a positive charge and because
of that it can be trapped using electric forces so
they have this trapped ion and because it has one
lonesome electron remaining in its veence shell
they can actually manipulate that electron with
laser so hitting it with a laser might be able to
put it up into its excited state and then coming
down again it can go back to its ground state
probably emitting light in the process and that's
how they're able to control this qubit using
lasers and electric forces and voltages though
they might be small now in terms of the number
of qubits rather than the overall size quantum
computers are real and available for anyone to
use many labs and institutions are in to make
them better and today you can write programs that
run on quantum computers quantum computers aren't
just good for simulating nature they are also
powerful at solving other problems that also get
exponentially more complex such as optimization
and cryptography quantum computers have the
potential to improve many different fields and
industries drastically but if the problem doesn't
have exponential complexity then you wouldn't need
a quantum computer to solve it you'd be better off
sticking to regular computers Feynman finished his
speech by saying he's not happy with attempts to
model physics just using classical theory because
nature isn't classical damn it and if you want to
make a simulation of nature you'd better make it
quantum mechanical and by golly it's a wonderful
problem because it doesn't look so easy so why
don't we see quantum computers everywhere already
well it comes back to what Feynman said Quantum
Computing isn't easy and many smart people are
trying to work out its challenges one of them
is noise quantum computers like all electronic
devices can experience interference imagine a
phone call getting disrupted similarly quantum
computers can get affected by various sources
such as electromagnetic waves from Wi-Fi or
fluctuations in Earth's magnetic field this
interference causes the data in qubits to degrade
traditional computers are relatively resilient
their building blocks transistors can perform
billions of operations every second for countless
years without any interference induced faults on
the other hand quantum computers are delicate a
qubit can become unpredictable from interference
in mere milliseconds quantum information is
actually very fragile even a measurement can
destroy it that's why we don't take a measurement
of the quantum state until until probably the
last step in our process because we don't want to
destroy that state before we finished performing
the computation and as it says here more is worse
when it comes to cubits because they each bring
their own noise and there's additional noise when
the qubits are connected together the more qubits
you have the more difficult it is to protect
that fragile quantum information it says here
that someone moving a chair in the lab housing
the quantum computer is enough to change qubit so
there's an almost endless list of possible errors
the quantum computers that we have today are
small and noisy so we can't use them for the same
things that we would want to use a perfect quantum
computer for and instead we are currently looking
for things that are okay to use a noisy quantum
computer for there's actually a name for the era
of quantum computing that we're currently in which
is NISQ or noisy intermediate scale quantum and
this plot here shows the situation the green line
is digital technology or normal computers and it
shows that in the past in what they've called the
digital era these normal computers were better
at doing things they had more computational power
than the early quantum technology but the power
of these technologies is getting closer until this
point here where it's going to cross over this is
the point when quantum technology is going to be
able to do more than what digital technology can
do that's going to be really soon for us and going
to be really exciting because after that point
the quantum technology will continue climbing
and the gap will get wider between what quantum
computers are able to achieve and what digital
technology could that would be the quantum era it
says here that when a device is built with a few
hundred qubits not even all the digital computers
in the world working together would be able to
store its state in memory and so with just a
few hundred qubits we'll be able to do things
that no digital computer would ever be able to
do the only thing really standing in our way and
preventing us from building one right now is noise
one way to reduce noise is with error correction
error correction algorithms have been made and
used for conventional computer chips like the
ones that are up in space they needed to be more
resilient to radiation that could cause errors for
the quantum version of error correction the key
idea is to encode a single qubit of information
across multiple physical qubits creating a form
of redundancy by spreading the information out
and entangling the qubits any errors that occur
can be detected and corrected without directly
measuring the qubit's value thus preserving the
quantum information inevitably some qubits will
go bad but if at least half is still good then
you should be able to correct them the problem
with this approach is that it requires more qubits
which bring their own noise and then the number of
qubits required to perform basic error correction
balloons out to dwarf the original qubits by as
much as a thousand to1 it's theoretically
a viable approach but right now there's a
global research effort just trying to get to the
break even point where it's actually beneficial
to use quantum error correction given how many
resources it takes the other more obvious way to
reduce noise is in the hardware itself in cooling
the quantum computer to below the temperature of
outer space and shielding it from the surrounding
environment scientists are also exploring the very
best and least noisy materials that they can use
to make the qubit but there's one other approach
to reducing noise that's kind of in between these
two it can be thought of as quantum firmware and
protects the qubit against noise without needing
extra qubits one method is dynamic stabilization
which applies a sequence of precisely timed pulses
to the qubits these pulses effectively refocus the
qubits and counteract the effects of unwanted
external noise this concept is somewhat similar
to techniques used in medical MRI scans where
timed pulses help to produce clearer images the
goal of dynamic stabilization is to average out or
nullify the effects of environmental disturbances
over time and as a result the cubits are able to
maintain their quantum state for longer allowing
for more accurate quantum computations some noise
sources might not be mitigated by this technique
alone so dynamic stabilization is often used in
combination with other error correction and noise
reduction strategies Q-CTRL who is the sponsor
of today's video specialize in making this kind
of quantum firmware their software helps to make
today's quantum computers actually useful they
also have an educational platform called Black
Opal which teaches skills that would be useful in
the quantum computing era I have enjoyed working
through their course on quantum fundamentals
Black Opal allows you to build interactive
circuits and this is my favorite part seeing
the relationship between parts of a circuit
and what's going on with the state of the qubit
X is a quantum gate that is analogous
to the not gate in classical computing
so it will change a zero to a 1 or a 1
to a zero and it does that by rotating
180° around the x axis the Y and Zed
do the same but by rotating around
their axes and combining them you
can trace a path around the qubit
H is the Hadarmard gate which puts the qubit
into a super position but between zero and 1
so halfway between each state there's a link in
the description where you can sign up for free to
see for yourself if you would enjoy diving deeper
into some of these quantum ideas and you can use
the offer code TIBEES to get 20% off their Pro
Plan this could be the start of your journey into
a career in quantum technology after all there are
many Quantum Computing companies out there now and
they all need to hire people of all types not just
physicists but software engineers and marketers
product managers and designers and understanding
the fundamentals of quantum Computing can really
help to get into those jobs in Quantum Computing
companies too thank you to Q-CTRL for sponsoring
this video and thank you for watching also
thank you to my patreon supporters for making
these videos possible and a special shout out to
today's patreon cats of the day Duchess and Rudy